this is
the ramsay show you can be intentional
about your character
you can have money and a career you are
the hero
in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host
thank you for joining us extra special
day
here at the ramsey show in ramsey
headquarters
our good friends joshua milburn and ryan
nicodemus known as the minimalists are
visiting
with us we love these guys we love the
work that they do
and it is so akin to teaching you people
to live on
less than you make a concept congress
can't grasp
so uh honored to have my friends here in
the studio guys thanks for joining us
hey we're honored to be here thanks for
having us dave we love you brother
you too man so uh the new doc is out les
is now on netflix and it's a
huge hit i mean it's as always with you
guys
the only the only thing you had that
harmed it was you put me in it but um
and so all the dave haters now hate the
minimalist it's mandatory to
to cancel somebody for something but man
but anyway it's it's fabulous
it's very well produced i love the
scenes and uh your artistic touch as
always standing in front of the brick
walls and stuff and the anger camera
angles and
the reenactments of when you were
working and all that kind of stuff it's
very well done guys did you have fun on
it
oh man so much fun i wish i could say
that we had you know something to do
with that art piece of it but really
our director matt diabella he is a
savant
so yeah the videography really um i got
to give it up to matt i got to give
credible credit's due but yeah we had a
lot of fun making it and
i'm really glad to see it uh uh going
across the tv screens all across the
world
yeah it's gone gone huge okay let's
backtrack because
there might be someone out there who
just emerged from a cave and never heard
who the minimalists are
and so we should uh upgrade uh their
knowledge
and catch them up to where the rest of
us are so
minimalism and the minimalists uh
give me the two-minute version of what
it is and how you got here
yeah so it really started with two
events in my life my mother died my
marriage ended both in the same month i
was 28 years old
sort of at the pinnacle of my corporate
career i was ostensibly successful had
all the trappings of
the american dream but for me that also
meant a lot of debt
a lot of stress a lot of anxiety and of
course in our world
a lot of stuff the average american
household has 300 000 items in it
i've had all of those things and more
and it's not there's anything inherently
wrong with the things the problem is
that i had so much stuff
that i was forsaking the people closest
to me
and i realized that all of my priorities
were out of whack i was
so focused on so-called success and
achievement and stuff
accumulating these things they weren't
making me happy
they weren't doing their job and i
realized i needed to simplify my life
and that's really where this thing
called minimalism came in minimalism is
just the thing that gets us past the
thing so we can make room for life's
most important things
which aren't things at all that's not to
say that ryan and i are against
stuff the problem is we have so much
stuff it's actually getting in the way
of living a meaningful life
you know i mean we're like uh most of us
in america uh
we're just stuff obese i mean we just
have stuff coming out our ears when you
move
and you have a box i remember this when
i was when i was a kid when we were
moving
you have a box that says seldom used
kitchen items
that might be a sign that you have too
much stuff
sounds like another name for junk drawer
to me yeah yeah in the the
kitchen junk drawer seldom used kitsch
ronco apparently sold this crap i mean
you know i don't know
but we buy everything in sight and
because we're sold
everything inside what did you call it
in the documentary uh you called it
stuff itis right tough ida
yeah i mean we unfortunately uh
we we look at these things as a shortcut
we look at uh
purchasing the new car going on the
vacation buying the bigger house i know
for me
when i got into minimalism it was
because i wanted to get my time back and
the reason why i didn't have control of
my time is because i had so much debt
and to pay all of those debt payments i
had to work a crazy
uh crazy job 60 70 sometimes 80 hours a
week and every time i got a promotion i
never thought to myself
oh here's an opportunity for me to pay
off debt it was always an opportunity
for me to buy
more more yeah because i was looking for
a shortcut to happiness i was looking
for a shortcut to status a shortcut
for significance really in some ways
well and our messages have overlapped
for uh probably
close to a decade now uh where we just
say stuff like you know
it's okay to have a nice car it's just
not okay for a nice car to have you
that's exactly right
and you know it's the same kind of vibe
it's this whole thing no it's stuff is
not evil
but when you gorge yourself on stuff
you're
you're going to get satiated you're
never satisfied yeah it's
called the hedonic treadmill right yeah
we what we do is we we get something and
that becomes our new
baseline and so i went from the toyota
to the lexus and so when i had alexis i
all of a sudden i needed two lexuses lex
eye
[Laughter]
because i run an urge it was right there
one was not enough
in our culture it's always more and more
and more and more we never stop to
consider
less and the only way to consider less
is to identify what is enough
in my life and it when we identify we
have enough things
what are we making room for well we're
making room for our values we're making
room for contribution we're making
room for our family and friends the
people in our lives
it's much more about that than it is
about uh amassing more things
into our ever busy lifestyles so less
is more the old maximum is where you
came up with less is now
yeah because it's it's so cool to be now
and again when you want to read this is
not a thing to say you're spiritually
evil if you have stuff
no no it's nothing to say stuff is bad
at all no it's not the stuff's fault
no it's that we put it on a pedestal
right right absolutely
yeah i look at uh it's easy to do the
advertisements we see every day it's
over 5000 advertisements that's a lot of
noise it's a lot of things seeping into
our subconscious so
i mean the thing like minimalism really
helps us kind of sift through all that
noise and what i really like about
our documentary lessons now is it's
really
it's about starting over it's about
someone who is who is stressed out by
their stuff stressed out by debt
who really is looking to make a shift in
their life uh we have uh well we're
calling them everyday minimalists
in this documentary uh everyday people
who
have been have found a way to start over
whether they're single whether they have
families
and they've really been able to make
some major changes in their lives to to
live a more meaningful life
it's impossible to sit and watch the
thing
the documentary though and not just go
pause and go
god there's so much crap in this house
[Laughter]
i'm sorry or you're welcome i don't know
it's just useless you know i mean
it's just useless think about this dave
we've been using this word a lot lately
essential
essential businesses essential travel
but now we're a lot of us have been
stuck at home for more than we
bargained and all of a sudden we're
looking around saying what is essential
in this house
yeah and i thought i was gonna need all
these things especially if i'm spending
more time at home but it turns out
i need it less than ever it's just
getting in the way
the documentary is less is now by the
mental
minimalists uh ryan nicodemus joshua
milburn are with us
and uh you guys be sure and check it out
on netflix we're gonna come back and
talk a little bit more about this but
this is uh
this idea of minimizing this idea of
simplifying it's catching on it's a bit
the minimalists have created a huge
movement around this
and and it gives you good pause uh
psychologically
to tap the brakes a little bit and just
go okay what it what matters
what is real i'm gonna be intentional
with his life spiritually godliness with
contentment
is great gain let's breathe a little bit
maybe if amazon didn't show up at your
front porch for a whole week
life would go on thank you vray who knew
and gosh i mean you can whoo man i'm
telling you
wow all right we'll be back with these
guys for one more segment here in just a
second it's the minimalists
on the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs
and the ability to negotiate medical
costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash budget
we absolutely believe in it
joshua milburn ryan nicodemus the
minimalists are
with me for a half hour hanging out here
with us in nashville been friends with
these guys for some time now be sure and
check out theminimalist.com
to check out their podcast check out
their books that are coming out
the new doc came out in january on
netflix and it is a
major hit netflix is grinning it's the
second
hit with the documentary you've had with
them and so they
they love you guys of course because
you're making them bank
and uh it's a great it's a great it's a
great doc they allowed me to be in it
several of my friends are in it
people that we know and uh so again
we've got so many
values uh that overlapped that we've
been
brothers of another mother for some time
uh and then have gotten to be friends
off the back side of that yeah
so 240 billion dollars is spent on
advertising today
that's a lot of money yeah and
when you think just about what is spent
on a given item
or we think about the power now of
amazon or the power
of facebook marketing or uh
the power of the data collection that
google has on individuals to custom
offer
you things that you just can't do
without because the offer is so
dialed in to exactly who you are right
yeah i mean you really
if you don't have a lot of intellectual
prowess you are almost powerless
to the sway that they put over the top
of you in this
and so we end up with just what we're
talking about is the minimalists are
about minimizing your life
not stuff is evil not money is evil
not you're a bad person if you have a
nice car it's not that kind of stuff
this is not gnosticism it's minimalism
right and so but it is about make your
stuff
have meaning and when you've got so much
stuff you've just gorged on it
it's just like all you do is eat candy
and you've got
no no nutrition in your life your stuff
is giving you no nutrients yes
there's no happiness coming from it the
documentary is less is now
and with all this advertising money
spent we've all got to put our guards up
uh because otherwise we just get sucked
into this vortex of consumerism
materialism
and loss so you guys have helped so many
people by giving them a guideline
giving them a rule or a step so what's
the first thing if you go yeah dave i
agree with what you're saying i agree
with what
joshua and ryan are saying but so what
do i do now because i got a house full
of crap
or we start the film with a question how
might your life be better with less
and the reason we ask that question it
starts with the why too instead of the
how to the how to sort of manifest as
soon as you understand the why and
that's what i love
with what you do with your work is
helping people understand the benefits
of getting becoming debt-free the same
thing is the benefits of simplifying
your life
understanding the why for some people
it's financial freedom sometimes
it's getting your time back sometimes
it's improving your relationships
sometimes just i want less stuff to
clean
in my house my house is so full of
clutter but also realizing that
physical clutter is just a physical
manifestation of what's going on inside
this if you have a bunch of material
clutter
you have spiritual clutter mental
clutter emotional clutter
all of this internal clutter and it
starts with the stuff but as we start
decluttering that stuff
we're able to look inward we also have
some rules like we have 16 rules for
living with less on our website it's a
free ebook people can download
and i'll give you a couple of them here
one's the seasonality rule
we also call it the 90 90 rule if you
look at an item in your house
and say have i used this item in the
last 90 days
if not am i going to use it in the next
90 days if not i give myself
permission to let go and that covers all
seasons so right now if i did i use it
in the winter nope okay am i going to
use it in the spring
nope am i using the summer nope all
right let's get rid of it
so we hold on to so many items just in
case another rule we have the just in
case rule
think about everything that's a hoarder
rule right right
that's the hoarder excuse for everything
i might need this
later yeah in some hypothetical future
that doesn't actually exist and so
[Music]
anything that we're holding on to just
in case we can let go of because we can
replace it for less than 20
in less than 20 minutes think about this
though you never have to use the rule
once you get rid of it you don't miss
the thing
and you're able to move on as soon as
you like it's really cheap insurance and
it's definitely
cheaper than you know renting out a
storage unit every single month to keep
all that just in case stuff
that that adds up for sure yes indeed
yeah the just in case
surcharge oh wow there's one more
axon just in case yeah spontaneous
combustion rule so
if you have an item that's feeling a
little bit burdensome and you're
struggling has that put so much meaning
in it
of course if everything's precious
nothing is precious right
but if i'm putting so much meaning in
this but ask yourself how would i feel
if this item
spontaneously combusted right now how
would that make me feel
and if you'd feel a sense of relief
maybe it's time to let go
yeah yeah you know that does not mean
you can burn your house down
no okay another good place to start um i
think you mentioned uh
your daughter rachel had uh played this
game but the 30-day minimalism game or
the hashtag less is now challenge
it's a great great way to start because
it helps you get that momentum that you
need in order to start to decluttering
your life so the way it works is you
find a friend or a family member who
wants to get rid of some stuff and and
we know that decluttering could be a
little bit boring a little tedious
so this makes it fun because you bring
someone else in and then you make a bet
to see who can go uh the longest each
day of the month
getting rid of items so you start on day
one you get rid of one item then you go
to day two you get rid of two items and
then day three three items and then
okay so forth and so on you probably get
it uh whoever lasts the longest
wins if both people last the whole month
they both win because they would have
gotten rid of about 500 items each which
is a great start
yeah that's a lot of junk it is yeah but
you know watching the documentary it was
just like a thing of you know scotch
tape
that's one thing you know or what i mean
it doesn't have to be like you you sold
your car
right exactly exactly and that could be
a big item it can be it can be you
have to be you could also you know i
guess you could technically count like
you know
12 paper clips on day 12.
come on no cheating yeah that's right
that's for sure
so we're consumed with spending this
economy basically exists on spending so
i mean stimulus will stimulate things
yes stimulate things and uh what this
does
rachel talked about it over dinner one
night right because rachel of our three
kids is the spender and she's obviously
the one that
is on the television on the radio show
does a podcast on best-selling books on
money which is
irony of irony but the uh but rachel's
uh
her she talked about it was almost like
detoxing yes
you know it's a cleansing sense a sense
of
i just feel better yeah i'm complete in
an empty room
and so there's nothing wrong with the
stuff it enhances my life it augments my
life
but it's not me it's not part of my
identity unfortunately
it has become part of our identity i am
this thing
and we even use terms like i love my
truck or i love
my house or i love my bed there's
nothing wrong with enjoying things
we get confused when we love our truck
but i also love my wife
i love my daughter it's a little
different yeah yeah exactly a little
different
yeah the documentary is less is now it
is on netflix both of the documentaries
are still on netflix as a matter of fact
you can go see the original
and see the whole sequence that way if
you want to uh joshua milburn run
nicodemus are my guests
this half hour and um you know we want
people to take control their money we
want them to get out of debt
and how does minimalism fit into that i
mean that's really why i started um
i wanted to reclaim my time i was uh
like i said earlier i was working 60 70
sometimes
80 hours a week to pay all of these debt
payments
and uh yeah i saw minimalism as an
opportunity for me to simplify
for me to get rid of as much debt as
possible
and really i mean dave my original plan
was to go be a barista
i was going to go serve coffee 20 30
hours a week but in order to get there i
had to get rid of some stuff and i had
to get rid of some debt
now the minimalist was a beautiful
accident 10 years later i still hope to
be a barista one day by the way
okay just haven't got there yet we got a
machine out here if you don't make it so
much people coffee
espresso machine all right yeah we can
let you practice but but you know i
really just wanted to get my time back
and that's
that's what i think minimalism can help
anyone do anyone who is
dissatisfied with the status quo anyone
who wants an opportunity to start over i
think minimalism
is a way that people can do that it's i
don't i don't want people to mistake it
for
the way like we're not just saying
minimalism is but it's a way it's a tool
that people can use
well in an area that we're just so
overwhelmed it's time to get a little
underwhelmed
i mean about minimalism hey new book
coming out you guys come back in july
when this comes out
love people use things be watching for
it and probably learn about it at the
minimalist.com maybe a pre-purchase this
is an advanced reader copy i got
i'm not giving it back either love
people use things because the opposite
never works right amen we'll sign it for
you absolutely do it right now
thanks guys love you guys appreciate you
hanging out with us man thank you so
[Music]
much
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find
out more
[Music]
change of gears here on the ramsey show
i am dave ramsey your host
rachel cruz my co-host today and my
daughter
nice to have the minimalist guys drop in
always fun to see those guys they're
just the nicest guys on the planet
they're awesome
they're ridiculously nice actually oh
yeah well they're very nice and have an
incredible message
everything they do i'm like yes amen yes
yes and amen
yes and amen in the lobby of ramsay
solutions on the debt free stage
bobby and michelle are with us hey guys
how are you
hey dave hey rachel hi guys welcome good
to have you guys
and where do you guys live danville
virginia i love it and all the way to
nashville to do a debt-free screen yes
sir
fine how much have you guys paid off 139
970 and 92 cents
how long did this take six years good
for you and your range of income during
that time
29 000 up to 85 000 this year wow what
do y'all do for a living we're both
teachers
oh god oh how fun what do y'all teach i
teach
fourth grade and he teaches uh seventh
eighth grade math
ah good very cool so what kind of debt
was this hundred and forty thousand well
dave i'm sorry to say
everything we were normal actually most
of it was my debt
and uh i brought it into the marriage
six years ago and we took
fbu as uh our pre-marriage counseling
and um oh my gosh i just gotta tell you
as a man to bring that kind of debt into
a marriage and watch
that that settle on her um
was just very very difficult i've been
carrying that dead around for
almost 30 years didn't bother you till
you said it on her
did not and then i saw you know at first
she was like
oh my gosh it's not that bad we can
handle this we can do this
and then over the months i saw it settle
in on her and it really
broke my heart well the thing is too um
i'm i guess like a unicorn sort of i
never had debt i've never had a credit
score um
i had never taken out a car loan loans
to go to school nothing so
i love your parents i know right so i
never had debt but i never really had a
plan with money either so i still living
paycheck to paycheck
so when i met the love of my life i'm
just like oh that debt's not that bad
whatever
i never felt the weight of the debt um
wow
yeah his debt-free journey that that
debt got added little by little by
little
and then when we got married it's like
someone took 300 pounds and put it on my
shoulders and went hey here you go
enjoy carrying that so what he what he
was observing that heaviness was real
oh yeah yeah about about a year into our
marriage it um
yeah it was it was rough um and i
remember
our our budget meetings were
not good um we because we did
um fpu is pre-marriage counseling we've
never really had a money fight
but some of those budget meetings were
like okay how are we gonna
how are we gonna put food on the table
this month let's figure it out
so at 29 000 that year that first year
it was it was hard it was hard so what
was it mostly student loans
no a lot of student loans i've got a phd
so it was a lot of student loans
but um we had i had three credit cards
that had maxed out and over the years
we had to deal with creditors and so and
we've taught
almost 13 fpu classes i think i'm at our
church
and true true fact during some of those
fbu classes i was getting calls from
creditors
during the class during the class like
you know it it was hard dealing with
those creditors but we were able to
negotiate those settlements and stuff we
got sued by bank of america
um i actually went to court with a
briefcase and dealt with opposing
attorneys on that wow
a lot lots to tell there that we don't
have time but you know
just it was a long six years we made
several different job changes along the
way so that we could line up our
passions
with our financial goals and so now
we're getting ready to enter our first
uh summer break as teachers uh
completely debt-free we've moved into a
new house and uh working on our
baby step three inside wow just
absolutely loving life right now
and the bed the best thing is the kids
keep asking if we can do um
an actual vacation a real vacation
instead of day trips places ah
no dave trips wait a minute the real
vacation is the dave dress
come on i love it way to go you guys so
you guys i mean this journey for you all
cause you hear people
they start for different reasons right
you hear some people like yeah you know
i just realized uh all my money's
leaving so i'm gonna get out of debt so
i get my income you know
but you guys i mean it was out of out of
pain yes and it
is very visceral for me i know i'm gonna
break down and cry when we do our scream
and it's very appropriate that you guys
have the brave heart freedom because it
is very visceral for me
yeah so tell me so from that pain and
now you guys are on the other side
standing on the stage what was it like
like when you paid off that final debts
what are what emotionally how are you
feeling now so i
versus them yeah i think when we first
paid it off i kept
i kept waiting for something else to
happen and it didn't it didn't really
hit
um and then one day like i was just
driving in the car
and then i was thinking about it and i'm
like like oh my god
we're debt-free remember i cried all the
way home because i'm like oh my gosh
and it finally really really hit because
it felt like
especially early on when we would take
one step forward we'd get knocked back
um and we'd you know sell a bunch of
stuff and be like hey we're gonna throw
that towards debt
but then we had to put it in our budget
because we we couldn't pay the bills
um so i just kept waiting for something
to happen and then it clicked and i'm
like
oh my gosh like we actually did it yeah
it's amazing
i'm so proud of you for me you guys are
amazing thank you
for me it was uh not so much the the
final payment
and and calling her and telling her yeah
we just did it but
the next week i checked my fico score
for the very first time in my life
and after being hounded by creditors
after walking into court with a
briefcase to you know because bank of
america had sued us
i did a credit check for the first time
and it
said there's no way to determine your
credit score because you don't have
enough credit history
you joined the club baby i love
it you joined the club she was already a
member
that is so awesome we are weird so when
people ask
and they say you paid off 140
000 how did you do that what do you tell
them the secret is
oh my gosh um god um because that's
that's something that's you know your
faith is something that you'll
you always have no matter what you know
numbers in your bank account
um budgeting and absolutely teamwork um
i think yeah i think because we did fpu
as kind of our pre-marriage counseling
we were both on the same plan and on the
same team
yeah and so when it came down to a
question with money or
or a budget or anything we just kind of
fell back to that teaching
um from the class we'd been through and
it's odd like we really have
never had a money fight and we've cried
together
oh my gosh so much so much um
or been angry at bank of america
together oh yeah yeah yes um
but i think sometimes too um god has
definitely gotten us
through a lot of it because there were
times where you know i was breaking down
and he couldn't break down so he had to
rely on his faith to be stronger
the other way around i know one week in
particular we had
a horrific budget meeting it was so bad
like we could barely afford anything
so all week long when anything bad
happened my first thought was
it's a train it that's a train and so we
went to church that sunday
and they had a guest preacher and he
pointed
us to and brought us up can everyone
else was up at the altar and he looked
at me and he said hey
it's a light and i'm like oh god thank
you
so sometimes we yeah and i'm just like
and i'm like why did you say that he's
like i don't know
just i felt like i needed to give you
that message and i'm like oh
thank you jesus for those of you don't
know it's a light
at the end of the tunnel that is not an
oncoming train it's a phrase we say
around here all the time
so that puts that whole thing into
context wow you guys
amazing amazing amazing if i could say
one thing to the people listening out
there you know there are a lot of calls
that free calls and debt free people and
i don't want to take away from any
any of it but um six years is a long
time
yeah and we went through a lot over
those six years we cash flowed a bunch
of surgeries there were a lot of ups and
downs
but we always stayed committed i just
want to tell those people that are
listening out there
that that don't lose the faith i mean
you can keep
keep pushing it will happen be
intentional about
everything that you do with your money
amen bobby and michelle lynchburg
virginia 140 000 paid off
in six years making 29 to 85.
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three two one
that's what it sounds like after six
years right there oh
so much
[Music]
[Music]
so
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today
a selling author number one best-selling
author
of several books her latest is know
yourself
know your money new york times
best-selling book discover
why you handle money the way you do
and what to do about it now your money
conversations are
about to get a lot easier rachel just
launched the know it yours
know yourself money assessment
the assessment will guide you to lasting
progress towards your money goals and
better
money communication how does it do that
rachel yes well it's
an assessment which i love assessments
if you read the book you know at the
beginning i talk about
understanding myself more and you can do
that you know through whether it's the
enneagram or disc
or myers breaks but like even just
taking a test i'm like oh when you read
the report like that's me that's me i
just i love it because it gives so much
insight so
after doing this book i was like i want
people to be able to have these
conversations because the book revolves
so much around your money tendencies
your dreams your fears
how you grew up with money all of that
and to be able to have it in a place
that you can
read your results of of who you are
around money i think was just so
important for yourself but
also if you're married if you have you
know
um parents that you talk to your talk to
to about money your kids i mean all of
it so it's a very
relational type of tool to use for
yourself but also if you
are married specifically so it takes 15
minutes uh you answer a bunch of
questions and then you get a
30 page personalized
version of of all your results and if
you take it with someone
like with a spouse then their results
are on
your results page as well so you can
kind of match up to see okay where are
we
on the same page where are we different
all of it yeah why do you make decisions
the way you do are you
scarcity are you abundance are you a
saver are you a spender nerd
free spirit what are your money fears
versus your spouse's money fears
yeah and uh the our team that built this
this product is it's over the top
incredible i'm
so proud of the 30 pages that it spits
out for you
because it's going to have a line and
there's your little picture your
husband's little picture your wife's
little picture whatever
and you're looking right there and
you're going oh yeah and kind of knew
that but this kind of gives verbage to
it
and then you can talk about it it
becomes a communication tool
know yourself you know is number one
uh then number two you've got to know
your spouse
and you know why they do this and you
know when i you know when
your mom is a saver and when she has
that tendency towards saving
um she's really not trying to kill all
the fun
right right i just have to remember that
sometimes that's right that's right yeah
and
and to understand the why too so it kind
of gets down
very granular in all of that which is
which is so fun so
yeah you can take it obviously if you're
married with your spouse or even
just by yourself if you're single up
there and you just want to understand
more
of how you're wired with money okay this
is one of the best things that we have
put out in a
long time and i urge every one of you to
run over right now
take this assessment very quickly it's
at ramseysolutions.com it is the
know yourself money assessment
know yourself money assessment and we're
not charging that much for it what's the
price on it's not on here you don't know
uh the price point changed so to look at
to see how many okay
yeah we moved it around because i was
arguing with them about the price okay
because it's really it's really very
very reasonable i do i do know that
so be sure and check it out
ramseysolutions.com the know yourself
money assessment mark is in traverse
city michigan
hey mark welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave hi rachel how are you doing big
fans uh we
me my wife and i use your principles and
thank you so much for everything that
you've done
for uh my wife and my family's life
first of all well thank you
how can we help well i'm uh we're my
wife and i are in baby steps four five
and six right now we make about 130 140
000 a year and we've pulled up a bunch
of cash right now to pay for uh
my first vehicle post uh baby steps one
through uh three and
i'm replacing my beater essentially
right now and we have about 30
000 saved up right now to buy a half ton
pickup truck
that we're looking for but as you know
the
the housing market and the vehicle
market are almost identical on the
supply and demand issue that's having
with it right now and i'm a little leery
about trying to buy a vehicle that i
feel
is overvalued anywhere between five and
eight thousand dollars
only to have the supply chain issue get
corrected in this fall do you have any
opinions on uh
the vehicle market right now in regards
to that question
i don't have any opinions that would be
based in fact-only feelings
so i will qualify it with that but as
you've already
ascertained we those of us in business
have observed
that when the factories quit making new
things
the supply of new things was gone
meaning new cars
you can't find a new car certain brands
you can't still can't find them
they've cranked the factories back up
but you still still haven't gotten them
all the way the car lots
and when there's no new cars available
guess what that does it sends all the
new car buyers into the used car market
where the used car buyers already were
now you got twice as many people give or
take chasing the same number of cars
that is going to drive
price up artificially until the
marketplace gets some equilibrium
meaning that the supply of new comes in
again
and relaxes the used the strain on the
used car market relaxing the pricing
i don't know when that is i'll give you
a wild guess
but it's worth what you paid for it i'm
just telling you i have no idea
i'm going to guess and say by fall
you're going to get equilibrium in that
market
it may take longer in housing but
and specifically trucks i mean mark
honestly my team we were just doing a
deep dive on specific
used sections cars suvs
minivans like we've done these studies
and and found oh you
actually have some information no no
well just to say that trucks has been
our hardest
um sector of car i don't know how you
would say vehicle
type of car uh because they're they ne
they do not lose their value i mean they
trucks hold their value it's like but
not as much not as much but i mean like
it's honestly as we've done research to
find
good quality used trucks we've been
looking around the twenty five thousand
dollar
mark and they're hard to find so when
you said trucks specifically
for whatever reason that's even more so
because probably honestly constructions
put a strain on them
yeah yeah that's probably it's um the
other side the other side of this coin
is
that i have the current beater that i'm
driving around right now it's a 2007.
um you know i'm having to put a little
bit of money into it to keep it going
and so i'm just trying to figure out
when should i just
you know metaphorically pull the trigger
on buying the vehicle regardless of its
perceived value right now and that's i
guess that's where i'm struggling what's
your household income keep putting money
in
130 140 000 okay so if you overpaid by
five grand it does not end your life
no it does not so you know none of these
are going to end your life so
it's just a matter it's almost like a
game now it's just
you know yeah when do i buy this because
i just want it and by god i have the
money now now that i'm out of debt
um and it's not the end of the world uh
it's not like you know if you were gonna
say you're gonna lose 50 grand
making 130 we got to stop and think
about this a long time
but five grand i don't want to waste
five thousand dollars but five thousand
dollars over the scope of the next
decade really does not affect you
yeah yeah i agree with you i understand
yeah so at some point
at some point the stress is over and you
go i got the money i'm buying it
that's what my wife would say yeah but
you know and i don't know when no i'm
just saying i don't i'm not saying that
points today
it might be you say okay i'm gonna drive
this thing until uh the end of august or
until it gives me one more repair
equal to x and then i'm out of here
because i'm done screwing with this
thing okay
you know or whatever you could put any
kind you could put a timeline on it you
could put a money amount on the beat or
repair on it
and let that be your trigger to cause
you to jump ship and go do with the deal
um or you could say i'm just waiting on
these dadgum things to come back down
and then i'll do it
you know you could go you can put the
trigger on it wherever you want but
the point is if you really mess this up
you didn't mess up anything bad right
right given your ratios and your overall
situation
so pan back and look at the scope of
your life pan back and look at the other
thing and
and go how much longer or you know and
then that that frees you up to
start looking for a reasonably priced
truck today
and at any time you found one you could
just you could do it you don't have to
say i'm not going to be in the market
right you know like housing markets kind
of crazy you don't have to say
i'm not going to be in the market but
you can say i'm not going to bid up to
50 000
over what those houses are going for
just to get in line with the 43 of the
people that are white hot and have the
fever it's crazy
you can say i'm not going to get in that
line but i'm also going to kind of keep
poking around i might stumble into a
deal
might find a sweet little old lady who
wants to sell it to a guy just like me
you know and that's what you're looking
for right and that that you know you do
find those things and you don't find
them if you're not out there wandering
around
just what you want to avoid is getting
the fever it's the fever that'll get you
that puts us our the ramsay show in the
box
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
screen live on the show make sure you
visit thermsyshow.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host rachel cruz ramsey
personality
is my co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five
two two five it is a free call and some
say the advice is worth
exactly what you pay for it elizabeth is
with us in tyler texas to start off this
hour
hi elizabeth how are you hi
thank you for taking my call sure what's
up
okay so um my house shares a driveway
with three other homes
um in addition to that we also share a
sprinkler system that is all one system
for all the houses as well as a one
water meter for just the sprinkler
system
um so ever since the house was built
all the neighbors shipped in money
together into one account that one
neighbor manages to pay for the water
bill the upkeep
of the sprinkler system and since we're
doing all of that we also go ahead and
just do
a lawn service together um historically
who has done it she's just been in
control of it she's been there since the
beginning of the development
i'm sorry say that i didn't hear that
first part you broke up
what about the first of the development
what so
the lady who's been wanting it in the
past or
managing that account in the past she
was there from the very beginning
she is turning 92 to here and it is time
for her to pass it on to someone else
wow okay um yes
so i am willing to take care of it it's
very little work i mean on a typical
month we only have two bills
um just the water bill and the yard bill
um
so it's not a whole lot of work the
thing that has me concerned
is making sure it's set up properly in a
way where
the account where the money is held is
not considered
a business income account for me or
something that i totally control
so that everyone's protected i don't
want to get audited by the irs and get
in trouble and for them to
get business income but i also want my
neighbors to have
access to it if something were to happen
to me um you know if i were to
get in a car accident or something if
someone you know it's not my estate's
money it's
right their money um and so i'm trying
i'm not just looking for advice
on how to go about getting this set up
properly so that we're
all all protected equally you know
fairly
okay uh there's two or three things
involved one would be the legal
ownership of the money and the how the
account is set up
uh two would be the tax issue
and so and you can get as complicated as
you want to get here
i wouldn't over complicate it i'm
guessing that she just opened this
account in her name probably
and never reported it and wasn't worried
about an audit i'll bet you that's how
she was running it just out of her hip
pocket
i i'm fair i'm fairly certain that it's
correct it is technically a business
account
but it is under her social security
number at the moment which means that
technically she could have been taxed on
this if it were profitable if she were
ever audited
probably a fairly low likelihood and she
was willing to take that chance
um if you want to go a step beyond that
you need to just form an
entity and with the irs and get an e
i n number an electronic identification
number
and that's what you would get that's the
same number you would get if you got
if you formed an llc uh or a sub s corp
if
the that's the next step you could do is
form an llc i would not
too dead gum much trouble i would just
get an e-i-n
with the irs and if they ever approach
you just go it's a separate entity three
neighbors managing the account there's
no profit
and you could just blow it off in an
audit but if you put it in your social
or in
an entity that you run business out of
then you could end up it could end up
getting blended in
so just order an ein or order it takes
about
used to take 90 days online now i
probably didn't take that long probably
get one overnight now
uh and you just open that you use that
instead of a social security number to
open the account
and just open the account and give it a
name called the neighbors i don't care
and um the neighbor's water account i
don't know
and then you just throw you and then if
you if you have a written one-page
document
of agreement with your neighbors there's
never been any drama
so far right correct it's all
everyone's agreed to it yeah i mean i
guess technically if the house ever sold
to someone who didn't want to be a part
of it
that could in theory happen and i
wouldn't i really wouldn't go to the
expense to legally bind all this i
or to mess up one of your ownership
positions with this um
you just have to work that out with a
new neighbor one way or the other and it
might not be
relationally pretty but it won't be a
legal problem so anyway just
i would have a one-page document with
your neighbors
that just says in a letter form what it
says i'm not an attorney this is what i
would do personally
just so there's clear communication with
your neighbors put all of them
on the checking account and open a
checking account with a fresh ein
and i would just run it that way that's
how i would do it just keep it real
clean
if you want to go further you could form
a non-profit with a board and an llc
now you got to file tax return on that
every year and you got to file with your
state every year and it's a complete
pain in the butt for something like this
it's tremendous overkill
right um just follow-up question to that
i did look into getting an ein
um and you have to declare a responsible
party
yeah which means in a way it would still
be a tied to me is there any concern
i would i wouldn't worry about that the
big deal is in the event you're audited
you have a clear paper trail that this
is a separate entity and it has no
profit to it
it has no profit motive to it it's a
simple transactional account
screw you we're not owning any taxes on
it i mean you can beat this audit in 20
seconds
and if you don't then i'm going to beat
it in 20 minutes over the top of
somebody's head that's
that that's just a it's just a matter if
you've got to find somebody in the irs
has half a brain to explain it to that
might be a challenge but you gotta
you just have to work that through
if you have time i have a completely
different question i'm sorry i do not i
apologize
but thank you for the call i hope that
helps you we appreciate you joining us
open phones at 825-5225
is in gettysburg pennsylvania hey nate
how are you
good how's it going dave better than i
deserve what's up
great okay so my question here i'm
29 i make about 50 000 a year
now i have some medical debt uh mostly
like hospital and doctor bills that have
gone to my credit report
totaling up to about 16 to 17 000
i just started listening to your podcast
about three months ago
and back in november last year i did
something i
realized now i don't want to do and i
went and bought a car
and so now i've got this 21 22 000
of card debt and medical debt and i want
to get out of it i just few days ago
purchased the
total money makeover and i'm just
wondering where do i start
yeah it's a great question nate i mean
well specifically with the debt uh
paying how many how many medical debts
do you have that total that's 16
000 i want to say it's
about 11 10 or 11 things on my credit
report smaller ones
yeah yeah and then anything else besides
the car
that's it that's it well i would list
out all of those
i mean even though it's it's it's 10 or
11 of them but
listing about smallest to largest
starting with that smallest one and then
working your way down and the and the
car
thing yeah i mean the 22 000 you don't
have to sell it
it gets to a point that you could say
yeah it's not worth it anymore and see
what the hit was that you took
what's your household income yeah fifty
dollars
yeah you're right on the bubble that's a
lot of car that's a lot of 50 grand
yeah i'd probably consider reversing
that decision meaning selling the car
if it were me just because i'd want to
clean this mess up faster than that
and plow through that 16 000 in medical
debt using the debt snowball that'll get
you there you got the right tools coming
to you
and thank you for being a listener
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy
dollars a month
by switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com
and enter the promo code ramsey to save
50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host today also my daughter
author of three national four national
bestsellers
and the latest one know yourself know
your money
we are launching today the know yourself
money
assessment now this assessment is
incredible it will guide you to lasting
progress towards your money goals and
better money communication because you
will
understand yourself you'll understand
your money
tendencies your money fears your money
upbringing after you take the assessment
and your spouse can take it with you
it takes about 15 minutes to take it it
spits out 30 pages of
detailed and personalized insights
really end up knowing what's going on
don't you oh yeah every part of
why you see money the way you do from
your upbringing to your tendencies to
your fears your motivations your actions
all of it so it's uh it's always
fascinating i i love this stuff
personally i was excited
to work with the team on it because i
think assessments in general are just
so interesting well the quality poses a
lot so the quality of the research and
the quality of the
um i don't know the graphic detail
that it puts out the way the graphics
look is what i'm trying to say oh yes
yes
the way the graphics look the way it's
laid on the page to understand it oh
it's beautiful
really proud of our team well they did a
beautiful job really really really we
should have charged twice as much as
we're charging for it yeah well to that
point though honestly the visual
yes once you get your results the 30
pages yes like you're saying visually
yeah it just tells you it's so easy to
read and understand yeah
it's crazy it's wonderful in that regard
i remember a thousand years ago i took
the disc
assessment i mean i man it 30 years ago
so the first time i ever saw anything
like this and i was so amazing because i
had like 27 questions and it read my
mail
you know it's like this is who you are
i'm a high d high eye on the desk and
everybody kind of knows that
uh and but i went home i handed it to
sharon and she's reading through it and
she starts laughing and she goes oh this
is what's wrong with you
no that is me that's not what's wrong
with me
yeah i took her it took us about uh 10
years after that to convince her her
particular type of disc was not the
right one and everybody else was the
wrong one but
yeah but this tells you not who's right
or who's wrong it tells you what
your tendencies are and then you say
okay i have a tendency to be a spender
versus a saver so i have to guard
against the toxic version of that
yes and uh so on so it's only twenty
dollars to take it
thirty dollars for a couple so jump in
there take it with your spouse tonight
go to ramseysolutions.com the know
yourself money assessment you're taking
to the next level ramsey solutions.com
again 20 bucks for singles 30 for
couples we should have sure we should
have charged double
because it's it's really you're going to
get it you're going to go y'all aren't
charging enough
all right our question of the day comes
from blinds.com find out for yourself
why blinds.com
is the number one online retailer of
custom window coverings
you get free samples free shipping and
with the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey
to get the best possible deal today's
question comes from jamie in indiana
we follow the ramsey plan with our
finances and are trying to teach our
young
children the same principles we have a
chore chart and are learning
that they must work to get paid however
every time we see my parents
they give our children money it's
becoming difficult to keep them engaged
in the lessons we are trying to teach
when grandparents just hand them cash
how do we handle this situation you know
i've not started doing that yet i should
do that
i should mess up your parenting by
giving the kids cash no
no it's like the swing set example
that's always what i always tell people
at christmas that year when denise asked
for a swing
and you know and then y'all bought a
swing set she was like i just want to
fish your price
baby swing that's all i want and y'all
go and we and we literally looked at
each other me and the knees were like oh
it begins
here it is so it begins dave just throws
it out they
just went overboard and just yeah no but
but honestly jamie i'm like this this
is a this is a people have this question
a lot because grandparents
have the entitlement as they feel to do
whatever they want with the children
and then they send them on home and
you're like no we have a bedtime
all of this but um you know i wouldn't
be
crazy uptight jamie i mean i think
depending on the age of your kids and
depending on how much they're doing it
if they're just kind of having fun with
them there is a level where i give grace
to grandparents where they can love on
the kids
but if you find that it's truly
affecting like their character
and they really really really are saying
like i don't want to do chores because i
can just go to mimi and papa's and they
just give me money
then yeah then we probably want to
circle back and have a conversation with
the grandparents your parents
to say hey this is what we're trying to
implement in our home
and because of your generosity and your
big wonderful hearts
it is kind of messing with it but again
i'm so balanced in this because i know
some people jamie i'm not saying this is
you
can that are on the rams plane are very
legalistic like no if you do not
remember and then they don't allow any
amount of like gifts or grandparents to
be grandparents there's a level of that
that is life
but if it goes to the extreme then yeah
you may want to circle back and have a
conversation
yeah yeah and i i think um the question
i always ask
is um is this
really about you and your mom or is this
really about the kids getting money
and is there something else going on
that's a doctor john deloney thing
that's uh not really a money
grandparents i don't know how you know
it it's just like
your mother is overbearing and this is
one example where she's out of control
and has no boundaries
and uh so you decide to use this one to
come down on that overall issue
and so yeah if that's going on then
that's this is not the
way to fight the fight you got to fight
the fight a different way on that yep
so but again it's not going to screw it
up the other thing i will say is this
um they can go
uh to the next door neighbors and eat
ice cream
and you find out about it later and you
don't allow ice cream because of your
nutritional beliefs or whatever i'm
making up some bizarre example here but
i mean the kids are and that does not
give them permission to come home and
demand ice cream so
you know the the reason we teach
children how to handle money is not
really about money
it's really about them building a
generosity muscle building a saving
muscle
building a wise spending muscle
building a work ethic and so when we put
shores
on the refrigerator we're going to
incentivize you on the positive side
with money but at the end of the day
you're still
going to do the freaking chores because
it is my
job as your dad to make you learn how to
work
so that when you grow up you don't live
in my basement
and so i can explain that to a
four-year-old i could explain it to a
six-year-old i can explain to a 12 year
old
that yes your mimi and papa gave you
some money but we do this thing with
money here because i'm trying
to teach you that money comes from work
not me and papa
you're not going to get a trust fund
that you're going to live on the back of
a yacht so
you're going to have to learn to work
puppy and so i'm going to work with you
on that so yes they give you money and
that's nice but it doesn't give you an
exemption
right from feeding the dog that's right
that's your chore yeah
and so i'm going to play honey this is
why i'm teaching you this
honey you're going to do this it's not
really nice of you that you're telling
the why
you know there you go when rachel was
little it was just no just
shut up and do it yeah do it oh well now
we're gonna explain the why
you turned up you turned out no this is
so good
this is so good no but really it and
then it just becomes the point of
disobedience that's that's the hard
thing
because you do have kids like mine i'm
like they're so different one is
motivated to do it and should clean the
play room so like do i get my dollar
like she yeah and the other one just
basically
the compliant one and the rebellious yes
yes so you're gonna deal with that
anyway yeah
oh by the way when you tell the
rebellious one to do something and why
and they don't do it then you just tell
them they have to do it anyway all they
remember is that part
maybe so just in case maybe so just in
case
just the things do circle back the
middle
the middle child in our in my family now
you guys i am now
you guys kidding me you got you as a
middle child
four and i'm really sorry you're you're
your middle one
is absolutely wonderful
she is a rock star
she is so sweet and so
tough already she's her mom made
over it's great so yeah yeah that's a
good question because the boundary thing
with grandparents
is uh uh daloni and i were laughing
about this on the air the other day the
christmas one i bought all the kids
those big plastic cars and none of them
are big enough to drive them yet
yes and the whole living room was full
of them and it was like i completely
overdid it i loved it and nobody loved
it but me
i was the only one that had their own
two they can barely expect they can't
they can't even get into it they can't
walk yet but i got them a car
yeah so um yeah it's yeah you got to
have boundaries somewhere
but uh brand new that one of the
questions baloney and i had was a new
baby the first grand baby oh yeah
and that's the one that's the one where
you learn all this stuff interacting
with your grown kids
and your grandkids and how it's going to
turn out this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality
best-selling author
is my co-host today open phones at
825-5225
bill's in kansas city hey bill what's up
hey bill how's it going belfast hey dave
it's okay i knew what you meant it's all
good
yeah how can we help sir um hey
so um actually i had a quick question
for you um so
um i've actually moved cross country a
couple times now and i finally found
a city and a job that i like and was
thinking about
buying a house um i don't want to take
out a mortgage
um but and so so when i was taking
inventory of
what cash i had i found out i had about
a hundred grand
uh in a 529 um
that's kind of stuck there and you're
for you
yeah for me well my parents my parents
left over
my parents uh uh funded those assets um
for you to go to college
school that's correct and you didn't use
it why didn't you use it
well i had a full scholarship and and i
went to a cheap school so we already
when was that when did you go to the
cheap school
uh six seven years ago
okay uh what did the chief school what
are the cheap school
how many scholarships how many dollars
in scholarships did you get
in total about 20 grand okay
might not be worth the trouble but
here's what you can do
okay if you pull money out of a 529
there's a big penalty
as you know okay right uh you can leave
it in there
get married have kids use it for your
kids use it for your new wife okay
whatever use it for your phd whatever or
you could go back
and get some professional tax advice
because i don't know what to do with
something this old but here's the rule
on 529's
you can take out of a 529 whatever your
scholarship money was
equal to and have no penalties or taxes
and so if you had 20 000 in scholarships
you can pull 29
20 000 out of your 529 and have no taxes
or penalties on it
okay but we got to go back in the years
that you filed those tax returns or
didn't file those tax returns or
whatever
and it you may have to file like an
amended return to pull all that off
i don't know how that part will work but
in theory you can pull out how much
you had in scholarships if it was last
year it'd be real easy to do
okay and bill do you have kids are you
married got kids right
no no no no i'm single okay so
all right because the 529 can pass down
you can pass it down later you can just
let it sit there
but you can't use it for the house
without heavy penalties yeah
it's gonna be i think it's a 20 penalty
plus taxes
on all the growth so you're going to get
hammered
the 100 000 is going to turn into 60 by
the time you pull it out
if you use it for the house i would not
use it for that
unless i could find scholarship money to
apply against it do an amended return
and get the money out that way
that'd be the only way i could and then
you would just leave it to roll over to
his kids if he has kids in the future or
yeah open phones at triple eight eight
two five
five denise is with us denise is in
indianapolis hi denise how are you
i'm well how are you better than i
deserve what's up
that's what i thought i am
57 years old i'm hoping to retire in
five years
i'm a teacher and my salary is 43 000 a
year
i have retirement income from previous
jobs
uh two pensions that equal a thousand
dollars a month
and um
i have my three to six months
saved up i have six months saved up in
my emergency fund
my question is being this close to
retirement
uh and i didn't expect to retire uh on
my own by the way
divorced about five years ago so
recovering from that um i've got my six
months in my job is stable
i was wondering if i should take three
months of that salary
and put it into mutual funds instead of
letting the cash sit in the bank
denise do you have any other retirement
any other money to your name
i have a traditional ira
that's currently worth 14 000 and i have
a 401k
through my current job uh
currently sitting at uh around right
over 3
000 and i've got 15 of my uh
valerie going into that okay that's
great
um
when i hit 65 i have
the annuity that i got from the divorce
that will start paying me
800 bucks a month for the rest of my
life but it's between the 62 and 65 that
i have to bridge
okay and you live you live pretty
frugally obviously
okay yeah so yes i i would not put i
would just put it
rather than my mortgage yeah i just put
it in a straight mutual fund i would not
put it into a retirement account
because that way if you run into a more
than three month emergency you can still
get at it but we really aren't going to
use it for that we're really using it
for long-term investing
but you're comfortable with the
three-month side
of the three to six months because you
live frugally and you've got access to
these other monies
coming in and stability of income off of
the old pensions and that kind of stuff
right
right yeah yeah so that's fine to do
i wouldn't i just you can't call it your
emergency fund if you put it in mutual
funds that's just my rule
right because i don't want people
putting their emergency fund in mutual
funds because then
transmission goes out the mutual fund's
down and then you'll go put it on a
credit card because you don't want to
cash out your investment while it's down
and all this kind of crap starts to play
you use the wrong tool for the wrong job
then
but the three months of emergency fund
on the three to six month range
in your situation is fine because do you
have kids at home denise
anyone depended upon yeah so it's just
yeah it's you
at this point which is just yeah you're
you're honestly the
textbook when we teach who should have
three months and who should kind of gear
more to that six months
you are textbook three month i mean you
it's you
um not a ton of you know dependents
there in the home
income is stable it's not like you do
freelance work and you have up and down
months i mean all of that so yeah denise
i think
leaving three months in there is a great
plan exactly and
all the other indications and everything
else you've described indicates you live
very much within your means and very
frugally
the whole way you described your life
says that yeah so you're going to do
just great
you're going to do fine with that now
the other thing is
stay with the 15 going into retirement
because that's going to be the big
answer to your retirement problem
not this extra three months going into a
mutual fund
this extra three months going into
mutual funds a fairly minor click
on the dial overall the big click on the
dial was when you start putting 15
of your income away and we start working
to get that house paid off
and you know when you hit 65 70 you've
got a paid for house
and you've built up a pretty good nest
egg by then over this next uh
eight to 17 years or whatever we end up
with here
so hey thanks for the call open phones
at triple eight eight two five
five two two five julia is in colorado
springs hi julia welcome to the ramsey
show
hi mr ramsay thank you for taking my
phone call sure what's up
all right i am a single parent working a
part-time job
and grateful to have that job after
being unemployed for two and a half
excuse me three years and i want to
thank you also for
your show i it saved my life so i really
appreciate your show thank you
thank you um i am calling to ask you i
did have to declare bankruptcy last year
um i had three credit cards they were
out of control
just so that i could put a roof over
mine in my son's head and provide
food etc just through a series of events
and i'm trying to build up my credit my
car is 16 years old i am
looking at going to college this fall
and right now in the apartments that i
live in i'm hoping to move out it's just
not somewhere
where i want to be yeah
you need to have learned your lesson
with the bankruptcy that credit is not
your supply
don't build up your credit don't go back
in debt it hasn't been a blessing to you
learn your lesson
don't build up your credit that's the
answer to your equation build up your
cash
build up money and we'll walk with you
and help you rebuild i've been right
where you are and scared like you've
been so you hang on
i'll have kelly pick up we'll get you
signed up for financial peace university
in a year of ramsay plus
we will teach you how to handle money
you do not need to build your credit
you need to build some wealth and we'll
show you how
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
rachel cruz ramsey personality is my
co-host
of this hour open phones at 825-5225 you
guys jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money michelle is with us in
scranton pennsylvania hi michelle how
are you
dave i'm great how are you thank you for
taking my call
sure what's up very exciting um
my husband and i are on our baby set too
it's been amazing and to encourage
people out there
if you're starting this journey at 58
it's not too late
and they can change your life so
and the second most important part is
that my husband wants to know what you
think
for investing and
would you advise sort of to hedge
against inflation
um buying like some gold coins as part
of your emergency fund
[Music]
okay um
no and i wouldn't suggest you buy stock
in home depot either
or apple or exxon
why because the price is too volatile
to use as an emergency fund the purpose
of the emergency fund is insurance
not investment it's there for the rainy
day the umbrella is there for rain
only it is not there to fight off bears
it's just for rain
that makes sense yes indeed
um so as
so let's say we have the emergency fund
in cash that's all you need
is an extra you can put it in the bank
in a savings account if you want
and michelle i'll go and i would go a
step further
too because you're wondering you said my
husband wanting to know about investing
and then specifically in gold but
nowhere in the baby steps do we
recommend people buy gold period so any
other single stocks either like he was
saying
but when it comes to investing in that
time still
not suggests investing in commodities or
anything like that so
in the market yes through good gross dog
mutual funds or in a retirement
vehicle like a roth ira 401k 403 b
but in general our piece of advice when
it comes to investing is to stay away
from gold
so let me kind of talk you through
something too that's interesting so what
this tells me by though and the way you
asked the question was that your
husband's
been reading crap on the internet okay
on gold sites because a
he should i buy this you said as a hedge
against
inflation okay now let's talk about how
that works
here's the way you've heard of a hedge
fund right
now a hedge against something
goes with the thing so the thing doesn't
destroy you
meaning that if you want to do a hedge
against inflation
you would have to buy things that are
incorporated
in inflation inflation
is the price of bread going up the price
of oil going up the price of housing
going up
the price of electricity going up uh the
price of living
going up gold is not one of those things
it does not follow inflation
there is no correlation between the
price of gold and inflation zero
there's no correlation between the stock
market going up the stock market going
down in gold
zero there is some loose correlations
that really what gold prices correlate
to is fear
or greed when the marketplace deems that
the world's falling apart
oh god and all the conspiracy theorists
come out
then the price of gold is going to go up
but that's what drives the price of gold
up
not anything else and so if you really
want to hedge against inflation you buy
real estate
you would buy stock in exxon you would
buy stock in wheat farms
you would buy stock in things that go up
in
cost when inflation goes up when the
price of things goes up
the things you'd buy stock in general
motors because the price of a car is
going to go up
you buy stock in bridgestone because the
price of tires are going to go up
that's a hedge against inflation gold
coins are not
the only place anybody says stuff like
that is on their stupid butt gold coin
websites
that's the only place that comes up
that's how i know where he's getting the
information
because it's technically the wrong
definition does that make sense
yes so when gold is going
up in price that's inflation
right that's inflation does gold hold
its value no
not necessarily you go back and pull the
gold you can just go online and pull up
gold prices
over 50 years and number one you're
gonna see about a five percent rate of
return
it's got a sucky rate of return and
it's a freaking roller coaster at six
flags to get there
it's way up and way down
just to get to an a boring average
that's why i don't play in it
because it's too freaking volatile it's
too crazy to ride and i don't find any
millionaires that say i got rich buying
gold coins
none i found a lot of people that got
poorer buying gold coins
but i don't find any millionaires in our
millionaire study that says i got rich
buying gold coins so this is where it
comes from
yeah and there but there is a level
because i just had a conversation with a
friend about this recently
there's like this level of security
feeling like yeah but gold feels safe
gold it feels like i don't know because
you can actually tangibly
touch it and see it whatever the case
may be there's this element of like oh
yeah we're gonna buy gold because it
just feels
it feels safer that's what they were
saying and here's what here's the weird
part of that is
it's not when when is it safe when do
you use gold coins
when you use a bar of gold to buy
something
never okay i mean go back
to a complete collapse of government
and anarchy in the streets you know what
happens then
the first type of economy that rises up
is a barter-based economy
so when katrina hits new orleans and
wipes the freaking place off the
map because all the levees broke and the
whole place is laying down on the floor
crying no one ran around with gold bars
buying stuff
but a can of gasoline some brand new
blue jeans
some work gloves some bullets you could
trade that for
anything for about six weeks down there
right now you can trade two befores for
just about anything in america
okay with the price of lumber yeah but
nobody's walking around with gold dust
in their pockets
this is not the wild wild west we have a
medium of exchange
primarily electronic but also these
little green paper
paper things with president's faces on
them that is our medium of exchange
so this anomaly this this weird thing
all gold is safe everything goes to gold
when all the when all hell breaks loose
the world falls apart
no it doesn't i mean you walk through
baghdad after they kill saddam hussein
nobody's walking around the streets
there with little gold bars doing stuff
immediately comes up with the next
dictator's face on a piece of paper
and this becomes your currency following
a barter black market barter economy
which is what follows anarchy so you go
from anarchy to stabilization
and there's always a currency that pops
up following with the next government
i mean when the civil war broke out the
south
they didn't run around with gold bars
they printed up southern money which
became worth
nothing once they were defeated right we
were defeated i was here i wasn't here
but i'd live here but
anyway but probably probably than that
old but anyway but the you know i mean
same thing i got these little pictures
of saddam hussein on paper money that
this guy in special forces brought me
back and three bullets from an ar right
when he was on a thing there and you
know what that paper money's worth
nothing
because the people that supported it are
worth nothing it's gone but there was
never any gold backing any of it up
but so why does fear drive it because
you see i mean like the joke is i feel
like
on cable news networks it's always gold
commercial you know commercials
selling gold and that's it's it's
on this false premise that if everything
goes to hell in a handbasket
you're safe and you're going to be okay
if you've got a gold bar in your safe
yeah well that's so much crap it's
unbelievable it just doesn't work that
way you know you cannot find a failed
economy
consequently a failed government that
has completely collapsed where
gold pops up as the standard it just
doesn't not in the last
300 years 500 years is you find me one
time in history you can study it you
can't
you know nazi germany hitler takes over
is on a failed economy by the way that's
what put hitler in place
okay and they had hyper inflation her
question was about inflation
hyperinflation
we'll borrow a load of money to buy a
dadgum loaf of bread so hitler comes in
to save the day he's going to fix
everything with a stimulus check you
know
so uh and goes into power that's what
happened
and but they never once went to a gold
standard
never once there was a lot of black
market stuff a lot of
trading back and forth but never once
did they do that so it's a fear-based
thing
and listen if you get your financial
advice on the same channel
where they sell walk-in bathtubs and
snuggies
you sh and your commercial breaks or
they're selling you financial products
right with snuggies and walk-in bathtubs
that should be a clue right there
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host thank you for joining
us america it is a free call at triple
eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple
eight eight two five five two two
five you jump in we'll talk about your
life and your money renee starts off
this hour in
iowa city iowa hi renee welcome to the
ramsey show
hi dave can you hear me okay yes ma'am
what's up
okay my husband and i have a small
business that is an s
corporation since we're employees of the
corporation
we receive paychecks do we
do we tied based on the paycheck
our household income which is our
paycheck
or do we tithe on the household income
and the profit of the business so we
leave the profit or
part of the profit into the business
well a sub s is all profit is
technically taxable
correct passes through it has no taxes
on itself all the tax
all the taxable income passes through to
your personal return
okay and so you're going to pay taxes on
it whether you leave it in the business
or not um so uh
what i generally try to do and this is
an exception but
i generally just say whatever i'm paying
taxes on that's my tithe
i'm tithing on that okay okay uh because
that helps me if i make a profit on this
or i don't make a profit on that or
whatever then if i if i got to pay taxes
on it means i made money
and so if i made money that's an
increase according to deuteronomy and i
tithe
on an increase i'm not legalistic about
it i just try to
over give just try to figure it out and
give a little bit more so
now here's what i do on my business
personally i do not tithe
on what i leave in the business as
retained earnings
because it may become an expense later
and won't be real profit it might be in
this calendar year profit
but next year it might be spent to cover
payroll during covit
correct so i do not tithe on it until i
take it home
even though that retained earnings
account is 100 taxable
okay so that's the exception to the rule
i use
of if it's taxable i tithe on it i don't
tithe on that
and it's taxable and the rationale is
that i leave it in the business
and so i mean i may leave two million
dollars in retained earnings or five
million dollars in retained earnings in
the business this year
and uh it might get be it might be spent
on computers next year
and so the net net is i did not have a
profit on that item it was expensed out
eventually it just wasn't in this
calendar year
um but you know it it you you really
can't mess this up because god's not mad
about the tithe okay and do you have a
time for a quick question
sure okay my husband and i our income is
a little over 150 000 we have no debts
we have no home mortgage
our business was paid for um and we have
a million dollars
and plus in our retirement way to go
thank you um but we're looking at a
second home
not to replace our first home but just
to have a vacation home
and we have 200 000 cash
for exist but the price would
unfortunately be around 500.
so we would probably do a mortgage i
wouldn't do it
okay a second home is a toy
yep and i've got a wonderful lake house
one of my favorite places on the planet
the number of hours i actually get to
spend there
versus what the thing costs is asinine
it absolutely it absolutely makes no
sense at all
and having a mortgage on it makes it
really stupid it's a
big old toy that's what a second home is
okay great thank you you pay cash for
toys
you don't buy them otherwise they're
toys
it's just straight up you've earned it
you've made a good money you want to
have some enjoyment
papade be throwing some kids off the
dock down there dragging them around
behind the boat trying to drown them all
summer we'll be doing some stuff
right but all of that is fun enjoyment
consumption and all of that is just like
it's like going on vacation you don't go
into debt to go on vacation that's
dumber than a rock people do it all the
time
but it's dumber than a rock and so you
just don't buy
toys you know if you've got a million
dollars and you want to buy a
50 000 uh classic car
well you've earned it that's fine get
your 50 000 classic car there's nothing
wrong with that
i'm not mad at you you got a million
dollars you got two million dollars you
got 10 million
whatever it is that's great get you a
stinking car that sits in the garage
for you to go down there and look at it
every so often and go i got a classic
car
because you drive it two days a year
maybe if the battery is charged can you
tell i know this
and so and it's okay there's nothing
wrong with that level of consumption as
long as it's a small percentage of your
world
and you are paying cash for it
now if you got 10 million dollars you
buy 50 000 car that's like somebody that
has a hundred thousand dollars going and
buying a biscuit
so it's not relevant to your life
financially mathematically so it's okay
to do
but always pay in cash and always be a
small percentage of your world
half million dollars out of a million
dollar net worth
now your business is probably worth
something your house probably worth
something you might have a two million
dollar worth
half a million dollar vacation homes a
bit high a fourth of your let's say you
got two million dollar net worth a
fourth of your net worth in a vacation
home
that's a little heavy that's a little
heavy i wouldn't be that high in a toy
uh but but again nothing wrong with it i
just the way i judge that is ratios
and can i pay cash audrey is in
cincinnati hi audrey how are you
i'm fine dave how how are you doing
better than i deserve what's up
well i have um a pending
problem my brother died in august
of last year and my 92 year old mom
lived with him so now she lives with me
but my dad had a 90-tillable
uh acre farm and all this needs to be
sold
a sporting goods business the farm has
two rental houses on it and my mother's
house is down there too
there's also acreage up on the mountain
that they go hunting on
who's that who's they um
well my uncle uh it's
a garner's farm
everybody hunts down there um
everybody who's everybody your family
yeah yeah okay all right so what's your
question
how should i um
orchestrate the sale of the farm my
uncle wants to buy it
is there any way that i won't i could
reduce
taxes if we sell it now
i don't really want to wait till my mom
passes away
to sell it because i have a lot on my
plate
um but what would be the best way to
handle all this
if you sell it now your mom's gonna pay
taxes on it on the sale
if you sell it after she passes there
won't be any taxes
okay she's 92.
yeah yeah i mean it's
it could be a lot of taxes this sounds
like an expensive property
i mean we could be talking about
hundreds of thousands of dollars i would
lease it to your uncle
with the promise to sell it to him for
market value at the time
that she passes you can get professional
estate tax
advice and double check me on that
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
all right going into the break audrey
called me from cincinnati
and uh her mom is 92 her dad has passed
and her uncle wants to buy the family
farm her mom's moved in with her but the
old family farm is
mom's old home place audrey wants to
clean it all up and get his soul to the
uncle before
mom passes just for the lack of hassle
and so forth uh audrey i want to circle
back on a couple things and make sure i
get better information and then also
say real slowly that you need to
meet with an estate planning attorney
that knows
taxes to keep from being charged out the
wazoo here okay
now yes and i'll teach you a little bit
of why
so your mom or your dad inherited the
property i assume your dad since your
uncle wants to
my dad bought the property he bought the
property when did he buy the property
um back in 1955
yeah okay so what do you think the whole
kitten caboodle is worth today
oh my gosh the the farms valued at
uh 300 over 300 000 the store
the sporting goods store is over 100 129
thousand
um my parents house is
um
over a hundred thousand and the mountain
the hunting mountain
and in that oh that that's
probably like 67
000. okay so let's call this 600 000
bucks and let's pretend your dad paid
almost nothing for it because that's the
truth
yeah okay so your mom
and your dad bought the property
together correct
correct okay and so your mom is now the
owner of the property
correct exactly yes so when you buy
something
for 10 000 or twenty thousand dollars or
fifty thousand dollars
and you sell it for six hundred you pay
capital gains tax on the difference
of fifteen percent and so taxes of
fifteen percent
on this are going to be a hundred
thousand dollars
okay if your mom sells it
if i understand what you've told me
correctly that's why i want you to get
detailed tax advice because it's too
much for a radio call okay
but okay the the principle is what they
paid for it is called their
basis yeah the basis your cost basis
from an accounting perspective
and the difference in what you sell it
for minus basis
is taxable at 15 or capital gains rate
okay
so that's that's the problem here now
if your mom not if your mom we're all
gonna pass
when your mom passes and you
inherit this or you and your siblings
inherited
your basis becomes market
value at the time of death
oh okay so if market value is 600 000
your basis it's called a stepped-up
basis
goes from 30 000 or whatever they paid
for in 1955
all the way up to 600 000 you turn
around sell it to your uncle for 600 000
you have zero gain
oh neat great that's why i'm saying
we're gonna wait until mom passes unless
there's another vehicle to do this
or unless i'm not understanding the
situation right when you meet with a
professional
in the estate tax planning world okay
okay now okay
now that that that's why i just said no
don't do it wait a mom dies okay
because it was taxes on 600 grand minus
whatever little they paid for it in 1955
which almost the whole stinking thing
gets taxed
okay that's what i'm trying to avoid now
the second thing that runs through my
mind is okay your mom is 92 your uncle
wants to buy this how old is your uncle
he's in it he's like 85. why does he
want to buy it at 85.
it's called a garner farm and
he and his brother owned it together his
son no his dad oh your your
farm your your dad bought it from his
dad
no no no my dad bought it his farm
separately but my uncle has a farm
right a journey uh adjoining it oh
he's wanting to combine this for his
kids yeah and keep it in the family
yeah okay that makes sense and he wants
to keep it in farmland
and not let buildings go on because now
that would be his prerogative if he owns
it
okay yeah absolutely that now now i
understand because otherwise i don't
understand why an 85 year old's all
happy to buy from a 92 year old
you know it doesn't just in general i
mean for his personal use no
but for his legacy yes yeah i get it
okay that makes sense because they've
hunted that property and farmed that
property adjacent to each other him and
his brother your dad
hung out together probably had a great
memories great relationships there's a
lot of
legacy tied to this dirt and that's cool
that's very cool okay so uh
again number one you're gonna see an
estate tax planning professional and you
understand why because the possible tax
implications
on 600 grand right and the remember the
phrase stepped up
basis yeah because that's what happens
on death
okay now the last thing then if
i'm right i think i am but if i'm right
on all those tax implications
what you could do is you could lease the
property
to your uncle for a dollar a year let
him take over and run
everything him and his boys or kids or
whatever and you don't have to run this
farm or the sporting goods store or
whatever it's just his
we're going to lease it to him as if he
owns it and he's gonna have the first
right of refusal
upon your mother's death to buy the
whole kit and caboodle in one fell swoop
for cash not financed by you
okay we're not getting into all that but
he has the right to buy it at 90 percent
of appraisal
oh okay and you're gonna have an
appraised when mom dies
and you're gonna sell it below appraisal
to him because if you sold it after she
died
you're going to have costs that are
going to be 10 or so to get rid of it
and you've already you don't have to go
through a realtor you don't have to go
through a bunch of rigamarole
you've got your buyer okay and the only
reason we're not selling it to him today
is taxes on six hundred grand
i thought that i would have to pay the
taxes no there is no taxes on inherited
property
no because it's because of stepped-up
basis that's the beauty of it
and um and if someone just leaves you
600 000
cash you don't have any taxes on that
inherited money does not have a tax on
it by the
person getting the inheritance so um
that's the beauty of it now there might
be some probate tax which is like an
inheritance tax at your in your local
state that's
possible in ohio i don't know what that
is uh or isn't
but um but but you can check on that
to be sure but that's not going to
change this number this number is going
to be driven by the capital gains on 600
grand that's what's going to blow this
up
and and make you and make you want to
lease it with an option or a first route
of refusal
by by your uncle and uh
and that kind of a thing and or his
heirs
if he pre-deceases your mom
he's got his boys or his kids or
whatever he wants to leave it to
right right right
and if they don't want to if they don't
want to buy it they don't have to you
can just sell it but
um at that time but uh that would keep
you from having to operate
which is your current hassle factor
right
okay all right that's a better answer
than going into the break and slamming
slamming you going okay uh no way to
shut up
[Laughter]
okay um what should i do because there's
two houses
on the property and mom's getting rental
money
about five hundred dollars a month what
should i be doing with that money
i wouldn't worry about injury don't
worry about it just let it in a bank
account
yeah sit there yeah and if you're gonna
rent the house if you're gonna rent the
property to him you might not count
those in it
you might let her keep getting that
rental rental income
oh if you're going to if you're only if
he's only going to pay a dollar you
don't want to give him the rental income
right
well he's he's already renting the farm
from these um yeah okay pays like a
thousand dollars every three months oh
well you could just leave all that alone
and then just give him a first route of
refusal right
if you don't mind operating the rentals
uh
on her behalf helping her with it then
that'd be fine
wow a lot going on it's amazing how much
effort we have to spend on america to
keep the government from taxing
something that we've already paid taxes
on
that's what they do with the state by
the way the death tax is they tax your
stuff
after they already taxed your income
that before you got to buy the stuff
this is called estate taxes you evil
rich people must be punished
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
family
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage matthew and candace are
with us hey guys how
are you hi dave hey dave welcome welcome
good to have you guys how are you
great where do you all live columbus
ohio
welcome to nashville thank you and all
the way to nashville to do a debt free
scream how much have you paid off
171 and 400 dollars
all right i love it how long did this
take
13 months whoa and your range of income
during that time
uh it's pretty much all of 2020 so it
was 235 thousand dollars
okay very cool all right so what kind of
debt was the 171 000
a little bit a little bit of everything
i'm going to read off my sheet here
okay uh 71 000 of student loans for
undergrad and graduate school 41 000
of credit cards uh 40 000 of a home
equity
loan that we uh paid off when we sold
our
uh 11 000 of some other personal loans a
401k
loan
4 600 of a car loan of medical bills
you're just more normal you're just
normal we were making really good money
and just spinning all of it and then
some
wow okay so tell me the story what
happened
well our story goes back longer than
13 months when 18 year old
matt and 18 year old candace started
signing
promissory notes to go to college to go
to graduate school and
we felt like we had no choice but to do
that
at the time and that just sent us on
a destructive path for 20 years and
we got to a point about exactly two
years ago where we said
we can't live like this anymore and
we have two young girls and i started
doing the calculations in my head
and college was coming fast for them
and there was no way we were
going to have them go to college and we
were going to still owe
all this money so we made a huge drastic
change
um we sold our house
we stole all of our furniture we sold
everything that was kids toys
wow we almost sold them
oh my gosh wow and we moved into an
apartment
and we're actually still in our
apartment because then the pandemic hit
and we were not expecting that so
that was a huge adjustment for us and um
we became debt free at the end of 2020
in december and we wrote that final
check
uh to pay off our largest student loan
and it felt so good and so
it's been a transition ever since then
um
so what did the house sell for about 350
000.
at a 40 home equity loan and what else
we we owed about 280 or so so after we
paid all the fees we netted
roughly 40 000 which the whole microwave
loan was just
a loan to pay off other credit cards it
wasn't much it wasn't much we weren't
yeah you just you just got out of the
payments yes yeah yeah
you cleared declared the home equity
loan in the process yeah yep exactly
wow wow very cool what do y'all do for a
living
i'm a social worker for a managed care
organization in columbus
and i actually work in finance supply
chain
oh good okay fun good for you guys all
right
so it built up and built up and built up
over the decades literally and then
about two years ago 18 months ago or so
uh something happened i mean what what
what i mean
you you just looked up i mean what what
is there you remember the day you
remember
yeah it was actually
um my daughter's my oldest daughter's
first communion
and uh we're catholic so she was dressed
in
her white dress her veil and she just
in the blink of an eye like grew up
right in front of me
and i think that hit me hard and i and i
knew we had to make
changes for our family um you always
talk about
changing your family tree and that was
it for us
we did it we did it for our girls we
wanted to give them
a head start in life and we didn't want
them to end up how we did
but we didn't know anybody so you came
home from the communion
and the two of you just sat down and
started talking or what
uh yes and no a few years before that my
friend james
bought me the total money makeover i
actually brought it here
since before 2014 i read it
hey these are some pretty good
principles let's just continue to be
normal
i read it again so i think it was
a matter of we didn't think we could do
it until we were both
in on it and really looking for like
this
plan that we're on it's not working
we're running we're sprinting toward
this never-ending debt
we turned around and we ran the other
way and uh we share our story with as
many people as we can
well not to mention uh dave when our
daughters were in daycare for all of
those years it was impossible
to really start your plan and um
to make all those payments we were
upside down in everything we would
stress about which bills we were going
to pay which ones we weren't going to
pay and it was
very stressful so yeah it was impossible
until you decided it was possible
it is so staying focused and we didn't
have a budget i can't believe how many
people i talked to today
they don't know where their money's
coming or going either yeah so once we
put that down and we say well we don't
need this don't need this
it became very real that the goal was
attainable during a pandemic year
yeah absolutely absolutely that's so
cool
yeah something happens emotionally that
that
it's belief hope i believe i can it's
hope that's real
that makes you go okay i'm willing to
sacrifice now because i wasn't willing
sacrifice if i didn't think it's going
to work
but something has to go over the line
and and sometimes it's something that
pushes you over the line
like looking at this uh little baby that
all of a sudden is a young woman
and you go wow this is going fast i
better get my act together and
sometimes when people have their first
child it's the same thing they go whoa
grown-up time now and you get real
serious about it something happens that
caused you to go uh
whatever it takes we're gonna do this by
gosh i mean my goodness
i'm so proud of y'all well done thank
you thank you not not only
paying off the debt but we've we got the
term insurance we got the mama bear
legal forms we got all of our stuff in
order
during this process too and we couldn't
wait till
until that paperwork was finalized so
that we just can breathe a little bit of
relief
during that time it feels good to have
your act together
it definitely does we're playing offense
and defense yes that's it it's wonderful
it only took this long
it's all right you got plenty of time
left you're just pups
you got plenty of time well done well
done all right what do you tell people
the key
to getting out of debt is a couple
things
definitely the budget we were doing that
every single day
the gazelle intensity the discipline
and the patience working as a team
communicating
side hustles all of all of these things
combined
definitely we're high school sweethearts
so we've been together a long long time
and i think the discipline in patience
was the biggest thing
um for us just sacrificing and as being
totally
selfless and just you know focused
very very focused yeah way to go guys
way to go proud of you thank you all
right and you brought your inspiration
with you what are their names and ages
oh yes this is greenlee she's 10 years
old
and this is bryn she's 8 years old
all right beautiful this is our why
absolutely
definitely makes us cry so absolutely
it's good stuff
that'll make you move mountains right
there yes well done you guys
thank you so much beautiful family i'm
so proud of y'all thank you way to go
heroes
we got a copy of the legacy journey for
you because that'll be the next chapter
in your story as you move on towards
wealth and legacy change family tree
changed and an extra copy of total money
makeover to give away
and be able to be able to pay it forward
so good stuff
i'm proud of you guys all right matthew
candice
greenlee greenlee and br brynn
are gonna do their debt free scream 171
thousand dollars paid off in 13 months
making 235
they sold their house they sold
everything but they're done
now they get a fresh clean slight start
count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream ready
three
two one we're done
[Applause]
yes yes yes yes yes this is how it's
done
i love it there you go man
family tree changed good good stuff
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 1 7
the fear of the lord is the beginning of
knowledge
fools despise wisdom and instruction
conrad hilton said success seems to be
connected with action
successful men keep moving they make
mistakes
but they don't quit well i can say i've
done
all of that keep moving make mistakes
don't quit done all of the above
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five
five two two five common sense for your
dollars and since tracy's with us in
tacoma
hi tracy welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
um my question is my mom passed away
a month ago and i'm the executor of room
yeah thank you um she lived a long
wonderful wife he was 93.
anyway um i've got we're
going through her will and we're taking
care of everything
selling the house selling the car and
everything
my husband and i are already everyday
millionaires we're worth about 2.3
2.4 maybe somewhere in there so i'm
going to be inheriting
probably 300 to 400 thousand dollars
from her estate once we've got
everything settled
well what how how do i go about
investing this i've got 66 for about
in a brokerage firm in mutual funds
125 000 in
cash in a mutual fund
and then there's going to be another
could maybe couple a hundred thousand
dollars after we
close out the escrow uh
the estate account and have the house
sold
and then i also had a kind of a side
question of
how do we figure out what the value of
the house is going to be
uh for tax purposes it's about 328.
zillow says it's about 450 and we're
starting to get the
real realtors coming in to take a peek
at it to do the assessment but yeah
that's that's where you find out the
value
there's going to be no taxes on the
house price because of what we call a
stepped-up
basis um and that is that when someone
passes away and you inherit property
your basis in the property becomes the
market value and you're going to sell it
within the year of her passing and so
that's going to be assumed to be market
value what you sell it for you're going
to have no taxes on the sale of the
house
yeah and mom and dad bought the house in
1961
doesn't matter yeah well that's
wonderful but i mean
doesn't matter for tax purposes because
your only tax number that matters is
you're going to sell it within the year
of her passing so you're not going to
have any taxes
and tax value for property tax purposes
is not an accurate value
and zillow is not an accurate value
zilla's in the ballpark
and it could be accurate but you need to
get with an with a real estate elp the
people that we recommend are endorsed
local providers that we recommend for
real estate
and have them put a valuation on it and
uh help you get
you know get it ready to sell and so
forth and figure out what you're going
to do there
so then you're going to take all of this
money and you're going to do what with
it
well um that's part of my question
because we've got
my husband's got a 401k of about 1.35
yeah you're already set i mean you got
three million dollars so
what are you going to do with this 400
well yeah we're not sure well we want to
be able to travel on some of it we want
to do
a couple of things to update our own
home
good it's full paid off but um
you know i want to be able to kind of
maximize the
you know earnings potential on the money
but i'm not
quite listen listen you have 3.3 million
dollars you've done it
you've already won the super bowl you're
good
okay so what i'm gonna do with this
money there's only three things you can
do with money
you can enjoy it you can be generous
with it giving it away
and you can invest it and what i would
do is just sit down with the yellow pad
and you and your husband talk about it
and put 400 000 at the top of the yellow
pad
and say all right how much are we going
to enjoy on a trip and a rehab on our
house
how much are we going to invest and how
much are we going to be generous to help
someone else get their start
right and you i don't care what number
you put on it
on on those three categories but break
it down into three categories
spending giving and
spending is enjoying giving generosity
and investing and you can do 90 percent
investing 5 5 you could do 90 generosity
you could do 90 spending and 5 on the
other two
you could do third third i don't care
you get to decide
because it's not going to affect your
life you were already set
before you got this money you can't mess
this up
exactly but that's the very thing that
i've been worried about is that you know
i want to be able to
honor the legacy of my mom and dad
well i think that if you don't blow it
all
that you've honored the legacy so i
think if you invested some of it they'll
be smiling
in heaven i think if you give some of it
they'll be smiling in heaven and i think
if you enjoy some of it they'll be
smiling in heaven am i right
yes that's what i would want for my kids
wouldn't you
yeah absolutely and that's what i want
for my own fun house yeah
yeah so we're modeling that we're going
hey when we got mom's money that's what
we did and by the way when you get our
money
that's what you're going to do
[Laughter]
yeah yeah and that's you know that
that's just a good healthy balance
where people get into toxicity it with
inherited money
is if it if they don't plan for it
and they don't and they leave out one of
the categories
i'm not going to spend any of it well
you should
i'm not going to give any of it well you
should i'm going to blow it all i'm not
going to invest a dime
well you should invest you know i mean
this is what people do
and you're not doing any of those tracy
because that's how you ended up with 3.3
million you're already doing all this
stuff
all i'm doing is telling you what you
already knew joel is in muscle shoals
alabama hi joe how are you
i'm doing great dave how are you better
than i deserve what's up
well first dave i just want to say thank
you so much because your message
has completely changed my life and my
family's life and our business so thank
you so much well thank you i'm proud of
you
how can we help today well um
so i i'm wondering here i have
uh 750 000 in my
business savings account i hate when
that happens
well we have uh no debt other than our
house
we have 135 000 on the house
um and i'm just wondering is it wise to
take money out of that business savings
account to
pay off the house yes or should
it is okay so i shouldn't hold off and
no
it's only 135 000 out of 750.
right your business is not going to skip
a beat and you're going to feel so
free you're going to want to run through
the backyard with no shoes on because
that grass is going to feel different
under your feet
oh yeah i can't wait for that feeling
awesome yeah that's
i i mean that answers it dave that's
exactly what i needed help with yeah i
mean if you want to spend 6 650 out of
750 i started asking you about cash flow
issues at your business
but 135 out of 750 dude we didn't you're
not even gonna notice it's gone
right right yeah i think it's just
sometimes it can
i guess maybe feel selfish or i don't
know
why i'm wrestling with it or just you
know taking money out of the business
although
it would hurt your house
your business
very true yeah dave that helps me out a
ton thank you you've done so good man
i'm so proud of you you're millionaire
man
you did it touchdown you own a paid for
business a paid for
house and i can tell from the numbers
we're dealing with that your net worth
is easily over a million dollars well
done
that's a couple millionaires in a row we
talked to here
and none of them talked about inheriting
it from their
rich mother did they oh we did talk
about an inheritance
it was 400 000 after they already had
3.3 so they were already millionaires
so don't talk to me about millionaires
getting inherited money and that's where
it comes from in america
people that say that don't know what the
crap they're talking about
statistically inaccurate i talk to them
every day and more than anybody else in
the history of america ever has
this is the ramsay show we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of
ramsay advice in their life let them
know about the ramsey call of the day
podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you